art 8h15 sur europe 1 alors de retrouver
sonia l'invocation invité ce matin
gérard larcher le président du sénat
gérard larcher
bienvenue à vous dans la gestion de la
crise sanitaire vous ne cessez de
demandé de la clarté ce que depuis que
le président a parlé on y voit plus
clair désormais on a un calendrier
on a des objectifs qui sont fixés
maintenant il s'agit de retrouver la
confiance parce que on a eu l'échec de
tester tracé isolé et aujourd'hui on a
deux défis à relever le défi que le
président de la république imposé en
quelque sorte par rapport à isoler le
second défi c'est de l'organisation des
campagnes vaccinales qui doivent
permettre de contribuer à côté des
gestes sanitaire des gestes barrières à
sortir enfin de cette pandémie
sur le premier point emmanuel macron
demande gérard larcher un débat
parlementaire sur le sujet ô combien
sensible de l' isolement des malades eu
copie à titre personnel est-ce que
d'isolement par la contrainte est une
nécessité pour vous d'abord débat
parlementaire ça ne suffit pas le vrai
débat du parlement c'est un projet de
loi et ça ne suffit pas de débattre et
d'avoir un vote sur cette matière sur
cette matière
on est vraiment dans une liberté
fondamentale
je préfère beau terme isoler le terme
s'isoler le premier des sujets c'est
complètement différent
c'est la responsabilité du citoyen et
nous avait répondu vous n'êtes pas pour
la contrainte rendez vous est pour
l'instant répondu civile et il doit y
avoir contraintes
elle doit respecter un certain nombre de
conditions le respect du secret médical
l'accompagnement des personnes les
clauses de cet isolement
voilà pourquoi ça mérite un débat en
profondeur
que seul un projet de loi peut apporter
avec cette sensibilité si particulière
du sénat de choses les libertés mais
aussi la proximité parce que
pardonnez-moi la proximité nous avions
tendu la main au gouvernement sur la
question des commerces en disant c'est
au préfet dialoguer avec les élus et
avec les organisations professionnelles
est ce que votre main était saisie n'a
pas été saisie raynaud regarder mais
regardez l'exemple des cultes
une règle unis vont partout entre
pardonnez-moi le temple de ma paroisse à
rambouillet et une grande église le même
chiffre de 30 n'a pas de chance et 6 des
six ans qui est intenable selon elle et
pas simplement intenable
on est sur une liberté fondamentale le
conseil d'état l'a rappelé il faut donc
que dialoguer dialoguer avec les cultes
pour voir dans quelles conditions
l'exercice du culte peut se dérouler en
respectant l'ensemble des conditions
sanitaires et des gestes vraiment je ne
comprends pas parce que l'exécutif dit
qu'il a dialogué avec les cultes avec le
responsable des des évêques de france
est-ce que selon vous il y a eu par
cette jauge de 30 personnes une erreur
d'appréciation ou bien l'exécutif selon
vous fait peu de cas et bien des
catholiques de france je sais pas qui
fait peu de cas des des cats likoud et
des autres cultes mais je crois que là
aussi la proximité le bon sens
c'est la première des réponses que nous
devons avoir et je dois dire que
rétropédaler l'oms pour passer de 30 à
autre chose
c'est pas la meilleure des conditions
pour recréer la confiance la parole de
l'état est importante la parole du
président de la république est
essentielle il lui faut de la stabilité
mais la stabilité ça veut dire dialogue
concertation préalable voilà pourquoi
j'ai dit que ne pas associer le
parlement
un certain nombre de décisions je prends
pas grande réunion où on est cinq ans je
parle le parlement tant que telle saisie
comme assemblée c'est me semble-t-il
indispensable en ces temps mais il
présidait ce débat entre liberté et
l'hindouisme en sciences
changez dites-nous ce matin pour nos
auditeurs qu'est ce que cela aurait
changé parce que les oppositions
notamment à droite laisse penser
qu'elles ont la solution magique pour
les français on n'a pas de solution
magique mais si je prends l'exemple des
commerces et j'y reviens quand à
l'unanimité le sénat vote un amendement
qui conflit à ceux qui sont les acteurs
du territoire
le fameux couple préfet maire si cher au
premier ministre dans un dialogue aussi
avec les organisations professionnelles
ce qu'on n'a pas proposé une solution à
l'unanimité voyez bien qu'on a
transformé tous les clivages politiques
une vous vous êtes prononcé gérard
larcher pour une vaccination obligatoire
elle ne le sera pas finalement est ce
que vous le regrettez j'ai dit aux
vaccinations obligatoires si nécessaire
je pense en effet que quand on se
vaccine se vaccinent pas uniquement pour
soi mais on crée en quelque sorte eu une
chaîne de solidarité sanitaires c'est
pas par hasard si il ya des décennies on
a rendu obligatoire notamment pour les
enfants diphtérie tétanos polio est donc
aujourd'hui nous attendons la mise en
place d'une stratégie vaccinale qui nous
soient proposés vous l'attendez vous
l'avez un petit peu mais c'est le
présent du sénat est impensable de
prendre que vous n'avez pas quand même
les détails d'un dispositif eco ah bon
la stratégie vaccinale et je pense que
c'est un sujet âgé parce qu'elle n'est
pas encore arrêtée on a nous monsieur
des madame on a une quantité de comités
dans une démocratie c'est d'abord le
dialogue entre l'exécutif le parlement
et les élus du territoire
voilà pourquoi j'ai dit au président de
la république il ya maintenant presque
trois semaines je l' ai dit au premier
ministre parle on ou yallah et nous pas
une il attendait à calais au secours
quand il faut trouver une formule pour
l' isolement
le quoi qu'il en coûte
ce sont des actes a dit le président
qu'il faudra rembourser je sûr
aujourd'hui nous avons pour cette année
sur doute fait appel à l'emprunt plus
que le budget notre déficit vous le
savez c'est aujourd'hui un déficit
important nous avons perdu 11 % de notre
production intérieure brute
il ya des réalités elle était sans doute
nécessaire parce que il faut être
solidaire et nous sommes en train hier
soir de l'avant voté la première partie
du budget avec des chiffres qui sont
déjà dépassés par les annonces du
président de la république fait la
veille
et d'ailleurs nous aurons demandé dans
la deuxième partie d'ajuster nos
chiffres et nous savons que nous aurons
au cours du premier trimestre en projet
de loi finances pour ajuster encore et
il ya des réalités faut dire aux
français que c'est pas de la monnaie qui
n'a pas du sang ce qu'il faudra jouer
alors on sait tous la vérité mais c'est
le prénom du synac comment résorber une
dette qui dépasse les 120 % du pib sans
augmenter les impôts des français de la
réponse n'est pas pour aujourd'hui on va
pas on va prendre les problèmes les uns
des ambitions mais il faudra aux enfants
il faudra à l'issue de la crise faire un
point rebasé financièrement de voir
quelles sont les perspectives
parce que sinon c'est les enfants mes
petits-enfants qui continueront à payer
la crise pandémique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
il faudra qu est une opération vérité
qui je l'espère viendra assez tôt pour
que nous retombions j'allais dire sur
nos deux jambes retombé sur ses deux
jambes également sur des textes
importants gérard larcher notamment le
texte sur la sécurité globale qui arrive
au sénat avec le fameux article 24 qui
fait polémique
qu'est ce qui va se passer au sénat
parce que certains sénateurs parle cet
article comme étant inapplicable et
inconstitutionnelle d'abord il nous faut
protéger nos gendarmes et et et nos
policiers ce texte on s'est focalisé sur
leurs tics 24 cette proposition de loi
de nos collègues députés et le visa ce
qu'on appelle un continuum de sécurité
depuis le maire jusqu'à la justice en
passant par policiers et gendarmes mais
aussi prévention et pénitentiaire
et donc c'est un texte qui s'inscrit
dans cette volonté d'assurer dans un
état de droit la sécurité l'article 24
vise à protéger gendarmes et policiers
mais sa rédaction
malgré quelques améliorations qui sort
de l'assemblée nationale nous semble
être une piste qui doit être ré analysé
revue navel deux objectifs la liberté de
la presse dont c'est sacré et c'est la
loi de 1881 mais dans une démocratie
elle est sacrée et la nécessaire
protection de gendarmes et les policiers
je pense que les réflexions qui sont
conduites par le président françois noël
buffet et non d'éditeur hui comme comme
philippe babin qui a justement il
daubresse président il dit il porte
atteinte à la liberté de la presse et
n'est d'aucune aide pour les forces de
l'ordre voilà pourquoi il faudra sans
doute en faire un article du code pénal
est inscrite manière claire et lisible
le délit et la liberté n'est le voir
d'une manière apaisée et pensaient que
le rôle d'une deuxième chambre
comme disait washington et jefferson
c'est de refroidir de tes trop chaude
alors on va parler justement la deuxième
chambre et la tasse de traits de tes
trop chaude sur un sujet brûlant il est
important que l'on en parle ce matin le
sénat a voté une résolution pour la
reconnaissance du haut-karabakh berceau
j'insiste de la civilisation arménienne
la chambre haute qui dénonce l'inaction
française qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
france n'est pas à la hauteur
le débat d'hier c'était d'abord un
devoir parce que c'est nos histoires nos
valeurs l'arménie
souvenons nous de ce qui s'est passé et
qui a été qualifié à juste titre de
génocide arménien c'est aussi 304 voix
hier avec simplement une seule voix
contre 304 voix pour dire on ne peut pas
laisser un peuple est encerclée et en
quelque sorte pris en étau c'est aussi
la protection d'une croyance d'une
civilisation et ça c'est notre démarche
c'est aussi l'urgence de l'aide
humanitaire
oui c'est l'urgence d'une enquête
internationale du retour des déplacés et
la proposition du sénat
c'est d'affirmer l'indépendance en temps
ce matin mais cette résolution si
importante à la quand même une portée
symbolique mais c'est le prénom ne sait
pas que symbolique
nous allons la faire partager par
d'autres parlements de l'union
européenne c'est d'ailleurs ma tâche
moi qui ai présidé les céda d'europe et
je ne veux pas simplement que ce soit en
quelque sorte un espèce d'ex voto nous
avons eu des moments parce que il ya des
moments où parlement où la question des
droits humains des droits des hommes et
des femmes du droit des peuples aussi à
disposer d'eux mêmes sont des âneries
essentielle où il avait de la france
sans présidentielle rendre où étaient
j'espère que l'évolution aux états unis
va permettre au groupe de minsk
notamment avec la russie avec les états
unis et la france les carottages qui
depuis 22 ans
c'est vrai est-ce que la clé c'est l'art
c'est ce que vous appelez le
gouvernement très concrètement à
s'appuyer sur les relations franco
russes parce que le psg a une influence
avec les jeunes eux genou je suis trop
lisse pour penser que c'est le parlement
qui fait la politique étrangère mais il
peut y contribuer et je ne vous cache
pas que je vais saisir
à l'issue de ce débat la présidente du
conseil de la fédération qui est le
sénat russe sur des sujets aussi
importants parce que ce sont des sujets
qui pour la russie sont aussi des
réalités
je pense que l'intérêt de la russie et
que nous trouvions une solution apaisée
mais je pense en même temps ces hommes
et ces femmes ces enfants déplacés
qui ont perdu tout simplement leur
maison la violence d'une guerre c'est
aussi des réalités humaines et cas
parlement s'en préoccupe c'est me
semble-t-il à l'honneur du parlement et
je voudrais saluer le fait que c'est
quasiment tous les présidents de groupe
du groupe communiste au groupe
républicain passant par les centristes
par balle un peu consolé le soutien des
radicaux me disais si dans leur note
et bien cette réalité là c'est quand
même c'est qu'au fond ces valeurs-là
sont pour nous les vraies valeurs que
nous portons dans la république c'est
l'honneur de la france merci gérard
larcher d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin bonne journée à vous à ses canaux
auditeurs bien sûr